more now on the supreme court's major
decision on gun access in this country
overturning new york state's handgun
licensing law and ruling that it
violates the second amendment infringes
on people's rights in this country it's
a decision that comes with particular
timing following a mass shooting that
killed 10 people in buffalo last month
and a deadly subway shooting in new york
city new york governor kathy hokel has
sharply criticized the ruling and says
that the state of new york will respond
and she joins us now governor hochul
thank you very much for being here and
thank you for all right there are people
who are cheering this ruling and i want
to get your response to them but also
your response to the ruling itself what
do you think new york state can do
to rein in guns after the supreme court
has said actually the
the second amendment extends outside the
home
we believe that the decision was
shocking in its scale and also
reprehensible given that we are
experiencing a nationwide gun violence
crisis so to strip away the ability of a
state like new york that's had a law in
the books for over a hundred years this
is not a recently enacted uh change in
how we manage our licensing we've always
done this the only thing that has
changed is the political composition of
the supreme court that being said we're
prepared to take action we have
legislation being drafted we plan to go
to a special session next week but to
those who are cheering this say we never
were taking away your right to possess a
gun but we have a right to restrict who
has it and where they use this gun
everybody in america recognizes that
there's a problem with gun violence and
the people who who cheer this what they
say what they see is look there is a
problem with gun violence and i as a law
abiding a citizen want to be able to
hold a gun on my person so that i feel
safer what do you say to that individual
i say that makes everyone else feel very
unsafe we don't know if you're provoked
you know you're in a bar and you're
having someone looks at your girlfriend
or your boyfriend the wrong way
there are so many triggers it is if
someone wants to have a legal gun
license protection in their home that is
their domain they can do that we've
always allowed that or for hunting and
other purposes but to think that someone
would be able to do this on a subway
in a crowded you know tense situation
during rush hour no no we have a right
to protect our citizens not take away
your right to own that's fine but where
you take it and the ability to conceal
it that's just going to make things so
much more complicated for law
enforcement and others yeah but back to
tony's the people that are sharing this
are saying it's not the guns that are a
problem it's the criminals that are
using the guns that are the problem and
here's what happens you have 25
of gun violence cases you know shootings
are with stolen guns yes they are stolen
from legal gun owners who didn't
properly lock them up or manage them so
we have to tighten up our laws we will
respond we have a strategy we've been
involving legal experts from all over
the country to make sure that we do the
next steps to let new yorkers know we're
going to protect them i heard something
interesting in the decision yesterday
that it should not impact the
restrictions of carrying firearms in
sensitive places
what is a sensitive place in the state
of new york is a subway a sensitive
place yeah that's an excellent question
and we are going to define sensitive
places in the legislation what's your
definition of a governor
it's hard to find a place that's not
sensitive in my judgment you know we
know what we have to do but places where
there's gatherings of people like could
be a sporting event you know rangers
games get a little rough and tumble uh
seems like no place is safe now well
think about this subways churches places
synagogues mosques you know places
religious gatherings places where
there's children daycare centers
there are a lot of vulnerable players
and also the right of a private property
owner a business owner owns a bar he may
not want someone or she may not want
someone to walk in with a concealed
carry so we're going to look at their
rights to protect their establishment as
well does this make this harder for
police to do their jobs do you think i
believe it will gail right it's going to
complicate things when a police officer
who's trained to identify and notice if
there's you know
some evidence of a bulge on a pocket or
something you know they're trained how
will they know whether this is someone
who's has an illegal gun about to go
commit a crime versus someone who may
have the concealed carry license so so
it's complicating things and they
already have a tough job to do we're
trying to protect people in our streets
and what we had in place for 100 years
in this state worked
didn't strip away rights
protect our citizens i'm the governor my
job is to protect the people of this
state and they've complicated this
tremendously and we're standing up let's
change gears for a little bit um
you we're also waiting for another major
supreme court decision which is the
possibility of the overturning of roe v
wade now you signed a package of bills
earlier this month which basically
provides protection for people seeking
abortions what are those
legal protections
we're protecting our abortion providers
from lawsuits brought by someone in
another state place like texas for
example they give people a private right
of action so they someone else who's not
even affected can sue an abortion
provider i want to make sure that our
providers in new york are protected we
pass that law also to make sure that our
providers have the resources they need
because there will be
a mass
mass migration of women in search of
reproductive freedom from other states
coming to new york so we had a beef up
uh with 35 million dollars to give them
the resources they need but you think
about the inconsistency of the supreme
court yeah
they're saying
that we'll leave it up to states to
restrict a woman's right to choose right
but you won't leave it up to me
to protect my citizens with gun safety
laws so states rights i'm not sure what
they're thinking all i know is this
seems like a very political agenda you
got a lot on your plate governor we sure
do but we're up for it thank you so much
thank you